there's a political Reckoning coming for
um for a cabal or a clique of world
leaders who are responsible on their
side of it for much of this so bush is
an example Tony Blair's an example uh
they invaded Iraq on false pretenses we
now know all of that was based on a lie
again back to Adam to your point that's
why I say we all have to take
responsibility for the full picture here
yeah and just like I believe Muslims
have to take responsibility to clean
house as well right which is what we've
been doing for the last uh since I I
left that group in 2008 uh with much
sacrifice but it's not easy to do what I
do uh and and me and my brothers what we
do is not easy because as you can
imagine it's faced with a lot of
pushback as well but everyone has to
take responsibility so there's a
political Reckoning coming because these
guys
um ruined the entire Middle East uh it
is I cannot overstate the damage that
the invasion of Iraq and then you know
with Afghanistan added to that and then
Syria and what happened there I cannot
overstate the damage that's done to the
world and how difficult it's made uh
everyone's jobs
um and they they haven't stopped I mean
during the covid Mandate period um again
for the record I opposed every single
covid mandate and lost my job over it I
was a national radio broadcaster in the
UK on the largest commercial radio
station but uh I basically opposed every
single mandate masks I flew in fact I
flew with um
uh to Tennessee without a mask on and
posted a photo and then the chief of
staff of the government wanted to meet
me when I landed because they tell me
about flying without a mask it was
surreal but um we've got it so just as
when that mandate period emerged and
Tony Blair started again pushing for
digital IDs and for synchronizing
everybody up with the technocracy these
people want Total Control it's why we
call them globalists they want total
technocratic control of everything we do
filter through their systems their
infrastructure with no privacy so they
can see and and hear everything
um and that's the same cabal that
invaded Iraq it's the same cabal that
has been through them the money
laundering in Ukraine and and pushing
for more and more war and the
securitization of our societies as a
result of that so there is a I think
there is a political Reckoning that is
long overdue and and I think Trump is
one manifestation of that political uh
Reckoning and in the UK Nigel farage is
an example of what happens when you
allow the established to get away with
impunity for decades committing crimes
invading countries there's still a CBS
60 Minutes clip of Madeleine Albright
the late Madeline Albright she's passed
away so I've met her as well I won't say
anything rude about dead people that's
uh profit teaches us
um he says do not abuse the dead for you
only harm the living so when we speak of
the dead people even if we oppose them
vehemently we speak in terms of uh ideas
and themes as opposed to making it
personal so she was asked by Leslie
Stahl on CBS 60 Minutes that half a
million children died in Iraq this is
the war before The Invasion and uh this
clip's still up online widely available
and Leslie style uh who I've also met
because they did a 60-minute segment on
me as well but Leslie style says to uh
Madeleine Albright you know that's half
a million children is the price worth it
and Madeleine Albright says yeah we
believe the price is worth it uh and
this is these these children died many
believe from the effects of depleted
uranium that was used in Iraq but the
you know you've got a situation where
the entire world has been ruined by this
cabal who continue to act with impunity
even here in the United States of
America I think I think Vinnie brought
up a very good point about the Bush
Administration I guess my question to
the follow-up is what level of
involvement should the United States
play in the Middle East obviously we got
out of Afghanistan Iraq was a disaster
we saw what happened with Isis and isil
uh but when when we leave the Middle
East that opens up a vacuum for Russia
to come in and Putin to do what he's
want to do China is investing in Iran
and different uh parts of the Middle
East you know obviously I don't I think
we've learned the hard way we can't just
place our values of democracy and
freedom into the Middle East and like
hey go for it guys yeah but should
America just completely
vacate Middle East like what level of
involvement should America I mean look
so let's start with that's a really good
I think it's a good exploration here
let's start with the aim I think the aim
should be
um
a more multilateral world that works
together
uh and so that doesn't mean Chinese
domination it doesn't mean Russian
domination so uh just over a year ago I
was on the JRE the Rogan uh podcast and
uh
um I believe he speaks highly of you
Patrick I saw a clip where he's very
happy with you
um I was warning at the time before this
whole Ukraine uh Saga sort of and the
FTX thing blew it up and the way it did
and I was saying this is all a mistake
because what we're doing is going to
push Russia and China together well
that's what's happened since they've
basically formed an alliance and it's
very interesting because if you see what
China's managed to do
nobody thought it would be possible to
pull from under the feet of everybody to
pull the rug in the way that they have
done between Saudi Arabia and Iran China
negotiated a peace deal between Saudi
Arabia and Iran which one hopes will
bring an end to the slaughter in Yemen
where it's been horrific with children
Starving in the way that you see the
images coming from Yemen it's terrible
so the hopes that what we're seeing now
let's take the Abraham Accords and the
UAE and Israel negotiating with each
other and now let's take Saudi and Iran
negotiating with each other the the Aram
Accords had American sponsorship the
Saudi Iran deal had Chinese sponsorship
if we can all recognize that this the
way forward isn't occupation Invasion
and funding Wars but funding and
sponsoring peace and these forms of
negotiations I'm I'm not opposed to
either of them the abrahamic or you may
well be aware of them Adam but the
Abraham Accords that's right and and it
was just you know the idea that
um Israel can have uh cooperation with
the Middle East and trade all the idea
that Saudi and Iran can do so neither
should be rejected we've got to stop
these wars because nothing good comes
from them and they're all proxy wars the
one in Yemen uh between the houthis and
the yemeni authorities was a proxy war
the houthis being effectively backed by
Iran and Saudi backing the yemeni
authorities and it led to mass law to
mass killing
um as well going on to this day that's
right but one hopes that this a
negotiated peace that's being between
Saudi and Iran China has been sponsoring
so now why I mentioned that is China has
made an offer to zelenski so what I've
been a very vocal critic of China I
before my cancellation I launched a well
it eventually turned out to be a four I
think it was four day hunger strike
um while I was on air and uh the aim was
to gather a hundred thousand signatures
on a parliamentary website which would
trigger a debate in Parliament to
recognize the plight of the oygar Muslim
people in China who are an ethnic
minority group that are being targeted
and discriminated against by the Chinese
Communist party because of course the
presence of any traditional religious
identity under communism is a problem
how do you pronounce it
um I I that pronunciation I won't vouch
for because I don't speak the oil
language we've heard uyghurs a million
times but so so the um is the head of
the UK world or you go to Congress okay
and she attempts to correct me when I
say uyghurs okay
um and the correction I can't vouch for
but how you heard me pronounce it there
isn't yeah don't take my word you just
say way more ethnic than I do I say like
a white guy
yeah so I I that is an example of me not
being a great fan of the Chinese regime
and but I try and give credit where
credit is due and we've got to recognize
that if we want the kind of world uh
that I hope we all want which is uh more
peaceful more united in in a spiritual
sense more multilateral then we've got
to recognize China exists and where
they're doing good like negotiating
peace between uh Iran and Saudi Arabia
we've got to say that's good so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]